uh these no no boner great
[Music]
[Applause]
two weeks in Europe it's gonna be great
I'm just gonna enjoy my trip I got with
MJ feel like really pretty and therefore
I have value no no that's not what I
meant
unless it with you that's really nice so
nice to finally meet you
spider-man here new cutie put some
clothes on let's go for a ride
unique theory just hijacked our summer
vacation
awesome
get gifts Parker but we have a job to do
you going to step up or not
we're all alone friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respected sub
hey everybody is Charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the second spider-man
far from home trailer with all the
different footage surprisingly enough
they dropped a couple different trailers
but Sony's done this in the past usually
Marvel Studios only releases one trailer
at a time so whatever we get a whole
bunch of extra footage let's break it
down there's a new round of that imax
ticket giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from this trailer on the
video the really important thing that I
did not talk about in my last trailer
video is the official poster the really
cool Easter eggs on the poster are all
the locations that they'll go to in the
movie as well as places that he's been
to in the past like Berlin like he's
been there in the airport battle because
of civil war but he's also going there
because there's a stamp that stated July
24th 2019 because of that very specific
date you know that this movie is taking
place within the context of the MCU
after the events of Avengers endgame so
if you ever wanted confirmation on when
the movie takes place in the timeline
this is your confirmation right here I
did not expect them to do this in the
trailer he actually goes to the passport
office to get it renewed but they
purposefully digitally removed the
actual date so you don't know when it's
supposed to take place so it's really
funny they would put so much time and
effort into removing it digitally from
the actual footage but not remove it
from the actual poster but the other
places that he's been or he will go to
during spider-man far from home are
Prague Czech Republic that's where the
big carnival fight scene takes place and
where they have those funny moments
inside the concert hall there's New York
City of course there's London there's
Venice Italy in another separate Italy
sticker so maybe there's a couple
locations they go to inside Italy but
Venice is where they pick up in a lot of
the footage where you see them driving
through the canals and you see them
checking in to a very notable Easter Egg
Hotel a lot of you may have noticed this
in the last trailer video that I did but
this hotel is named after a notable
spider-man comic book writer JM de
Mateus he wrote Cravens last hunt and a
bunch of spectacular spider-man stories
so there's probably gonna be a lot of
stuff named after famous people or
spider-man writers obviously we're
expecting a lot of Stanley's stuff in
the background so just keep your eyes
peeled for trailer footage
there were a bunch of those I included
in my last trailer video so I'll link
that at the end of this big surprise
apparently he's going to the Swiss Alps
even though that's been featured in the
MCU before like that's where Ironman had
his special conference in the flash back
at the beginning of Iron Man 3
that's where Arnim Zola is from it's
been mentioned on agents of shield a
bunch of times but these are meant to be
all the places that he's visiting
physically himself so whatever they do
there apparently it's a big part of the
movie the new footage opens up with that
Aunt May stark tech suit joke didn't
want you to forget this as he's in
customs arriving in the UK and they're
just inspecting all their gear like you
would normally do when you're traveling
like oh how did that get in there what's
what's going on and it just looks like
he's gonna crap his pants and then takes
the deepest sigh of relief in cinema
history it's the antithesis of Iron
Man's deep sigh of exasperation at the
guardians of the galaxy during Avengers
infinity war these know no banana great
what exactly is it that they do kick
names take
there's more footage of the other people
arriving at customs in the airports
there's Michelle there's Ned leaves and
Betty Brant pretty much confirming
they're a couple when you also consider
the other shots of them together in the
trailers
you see j.b smoove in the background
here we don't know who he's playing but
it seems like he's part of their school
group in some way if he's not a
chaperone it seems like he's doing
something else as part of their group a
lot of you were commenting that you
hoped that Remy he here is playing
Amadeus Cho but most of the kids that
are schoolmates of Peter originated in
the spider-man comics in their
spider-man specific because for the most
part those are all the characters that
Sony controls not Marvel Studios Sony
has the rights to anyone who originated
in a spider-man comic book which is like
900 characters so with very few cameo
exceptions and guest stars like Iron Man
for instance most of the characters that
you see them cast in solo spider-man
movies are specific to the spider-man
comics which is why my first thought
when I saw him is that maybe he could be
playing a young version of Martin Lee
mr- remember even the kids that play
comic book characters like this girl is
playing silk she doesn't look like she's
ever actually going to get powers in any
of these MCU movies because right now
Sony is actually developing a spin-off
venom verse silk movie with an adult
version of the character so take a lot
of these young kid comic book characters
with a grain of salt like Flash Thompson
here is probably never gonna be agent
venom in any of these MCU movies you get
more of them on that united flight they
also released another picture of them
but it's just them sitting around
there's probably couple funny moments
with them actually on the flight on the
way to the UK more them arriving at the
terminal with Martin stars character
leading them around I feel so bad for
him every time he's with those kids
some big disaster happen hopefully all
the kids parents don't lynch him after
they get back after all these crazy
adventures that they have there's a
longer scene of Michelle and Peter
walking and talking and what seems like
Prague Czech Republic she's wearing the
same jacket as when she's looking up at
this giant fire elemental so maybe this
is during the big carnival fight where
we see spider-man wearing his special
stealth suit getting into more Nick Fury
Easter eggs and Avengers endgame
backstory I know a lot of people are
wondering what his relationship with
spider-man is he's known about
spider-man
ever since Civil War when Ironman dug
him up he may have known about him
before that because he keeps files on
everyone so
superheroes popping up in vigilantes in
New York City area he probably knows
about them but this seems like the first
time that they actually meet in person
because he says so nice to meet you
spider-man but a lot of people heard
that and they're like hey wait a minute
why wouldn't they meet each other during
Avengers endgame because they were both
turned to dust and they'll be coming
back before the end of endgame and
there's gonna be a couple really big
crowd shots with everybody in the same
frame together so maybe it's one of
those situations where they're just lost
in the crowd and they don't have the
opportunity to like share a really close
scene together even though they're both
going to be in Avengers endgame pretty
much everybody from London that was
commenting on my last big trailer video
is positive that this building that he's
standing in is the shard which is the
tallest building in the UK in real life
and maybe Nick Fury has a shield office
there or just some other secret office
that he's using if you haven't heard
about them there are rumors that
European Marvel comic book characters
will appear during the film Jessica drew
Spider Woman was the biggest rumor but I
don't have any confirmation about that
the rumors just said that she was part
of the security force or shield that was
trying to handle all these elemental
things that are happening around Europe
so she could appear during the film but
remember when most of these new
characters debut they're just normal
people but I wouldn't expect them to do
any kind of spider-verse situation where
you have another person with Spyder
based powers I think that Peter will be
the only Spyder person in the MCU for
the foreseeable future we'll see if that
changes during phase four phase 5 if
they want to do a live action version of
Miles Morales he'd probably the next
person they go to Jessica drew would be
one of the bigger female characters they
could go to but the other big easter egg
that a lot of you guys have been talking
about is the illuminati symbol that
Mysterio gives off when he's weaving his
quote/unquote magic or his power I think
most of us are on the same page that
he's using his illusion tech that's
built into his suit to make it look like
he's a superhero and weaving all these
crazy spells and flying around when
really is just a lot of advanced
technology but the other thing I have
not seen people talking about is Doctor
Strange in all this if there are giant
elemental creatures wouldn't Doctor
Strange be the first person that you
would go to so I think Mysterio probably
just shows up out of nowhere and takes
down one of the elementals and that's
why Nick Fury is suspicious of him
because if there really was magic going
on and these were elemental creatures
from the Doctor Strange
then dr. strange himself would step in
because he's protecting the planet from
other dimensions and that's where the
elementals from his comics are from so I
think that's the dead giveaway that
these creatures are not what Mysterio
says they are and that's part of
spider-man's mission to find out what
this mystery is all about the official
synopsis even says as much so this is
what the official synopsis reads our
friendly neighborhood superhero decides
to join his best friends Ned MJ in the
rest of the gang in a European vacation
however Peters plan to leave the super
heroics behind for a few weeks are
quickly scrapped when he begrudgingly
agrees to help Nick Fury uncover the
mystery of several elemental creature
attacks creating havoc across the
continent so he just sounds like Nick
Fury is really suspicious of Mysterio
and by the end of the movie they will
find him out to be the villain or at
least creating all this havoc to make
himself look like a hero and then
they'll go after him then he'll
officially become a spider-man villain
but the way that Jake Gyllenhaal talks
about it is funny he makes it sound like
he and Peter Parker are gonna be Pallin
around defeating all these monsters but
they did confirm that Peter's
relationship with Mysterio is a core
part of the story of the film and you
don't see any of that during the trailer
so it'll probably be like the next big
trailer before we get any actually
footage of them interacting with each
other you also probably noticed that
Pepper Potts is the person who signed
that giant check that happy walks in
with Yoshi CEO of Stark Industries she's
been doing the day-to-day running of
Stark Industries ever since way back
around Iron Man 3 maybe even a little
bit before that so it is a big Iron Man
Easter Egg but it's not necessarily
confirmation that he dies during
Avengers endgame it doesn't come back
because Tony Stark typically wouldn't be
writing that Pepper Potts will be
writing that as head of Stark Industries
who's using one of their subsidiaries to
fund all those homeless shelters in and
around New York City because that's what
this whole speech seems like it's about
about helping homeless people in this
area don't worry there'll be a couple
people freaking out about Iron Man for a
while now like I said in the last
trailer video that I did with a
different footage they're trying to tell
you everything they can about Spider Man
far from home without telling you as
much as possible about Avengers end game
but there are a couple clues that I've
included in the video but let me know in
the comments how long do you think it's
going to take before Peter finds out
that Mysterio is probably behind all
these elemental creatures it will have
is is they'll be more Marvel stuff
happening later this week there's a
couple more trailers coming so I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
leave all your video requests in the
comments below click here to watch that
other spider-man far from home trailer
with all my Easter eggs and click here
to rewatch that big Captain Marvel
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]
you